We had to make changes in two classes, the car class and the stimulation class.
In the car class, we now return an ArrayList which is allocated here, we add a
passenger to that ArrayList, whenever one has reached his destination. And all
the way in the end, we return that ArrayList as the return value of the method.
Did you modify the Java Doc, to add an add return statement. If so, pat
yourself in the back. In the drives car method, we call the drive method. That
returns an ArrayList. For each person in that ArrayList, we print the drop off
message. Note, that I didn't even bother to save the return value of the drive
method in a variable. You can of course and you may find that it makes the code
easier to understand. But here I say c.drive returns an ArrayList. And for
every person in that ArrayList, I do something with this loop. Now, we have
achieved the goal of our reorganization. The car class no longer knows anything
about system.out. The Simulation class does, but that doesn't bother me so much
because that simulation class also needed to know about system.in to read the
user input. So the simulation class deals with input and output, the car and
person class are blessedly unaware of that. Congratulations for having worked
through such a complex example. Real life code does look like that, with lots
of classes. And in the next unit, you will see the Java way of organizing
related classes.